they kind of like dinosaurs but not in a
good way just inhibited in a terrifying
way like they could move it at any time
I don't like birds whether they're small
or big or whatever they're doing if it
is sitting there or flying I do not like
them at all
I have immediate fear of them they're
messy they [ __ ] on everything so you'd
feed I'm kind of scared they're gonna
just attack every single human being
there is a surprise element video please
don't bring it in bird love that noise
it's in front of my face yeah well not
yet
you can do it oh my god oh my god it's
this or yellow hey I think I'm cheating
on my hand my hand feels moist holy [ __ ]
he's so cute
I'm so not scared of it I'm Your Mother
now what look at the little wings it's
off as long as I look at it this way and
I can't see his eyes or his beak cause
he's super cute
it's kind of awkward though I feel I've
eaten a lot of these and it's really bad
I'm like sorry it's true people eat
ducks but you have to eat done dude I'm
really sorry I never thought I'll see
you at i/o the noise I can look at it
and I can appreciate its cuteness but I
can't carry it I feel like a good duck
mother like a horrible dumb father
this doesn't count as a bird it's not
flapping in my face it's not chewing on
my car this is the best surprise but I
think I've ever had his eyes are still
really freaking me out
when I look at them yeah like those cool
see these are what Raptors became so big
chill buddy eat me
this does not change how I feel about
birds at all hi I'm selamat freaked out
I definitely like birds a lot more after
today after looking at a duck in the
eyes I'm gonna try not eat duck now hate
birds
like fluffy things ah Levin here I'm
gonna me and my mum I love ducks I just
want to be a duck's wing and just be
surrounded by ducks for the rest of my
life to be honest